Hi and welcome to the Conor's clinic podcast. This is Michelle Hamburger and I am here with Jim
Kramer, who is the founder of EMF inspecting along with his wife, Loray. And EMF inspecting is
based out of the St. Paul Minneapolis area in Minnesota and they provide testing and consulting both
locally and on a national scale so at a distance to people who are wanting to do work on remediating EMFs
in their home and businesses. Thank you so much for being with me today Jim. Oh thank you Michelle
and I really appreciate you asking us and inviting us and it's an honor and a privilege and appreciate
what you do and so I'm excited to be here. So I wanted Jim to be on our podcast because we have been
hearing more and more information about 5G which is already rolling out and it plans to be in
full swing. I believe it's 2020 and my correct. Yeah and in fact it's already springing out the
Verizon chose two cities to start and they were Chicago and Minneapolis and so bring the final four
this last time. That's when they started 5G, the Minneapolis, downtown Minneapolis. Oh so weren't we
lucky? We were the first yeah we were the first trial. Okay it is hearing. Well with all of that there's
a lot of questions out there of really what are EMFs and are they safe for us? Are they dangerous for us?
So I want to start today with just the basics. So the first question that I think a lot of people actually
ask we like to believe that we're more educated on this topic than I think we are is what are EMFs?
Yeah and that's an important question and really this is new you know I mean they've been around but
it's just exponentially increased with for example in 1996 there was only 16% of people who had cell phones
and the cell phones were big they were like a walkie-talkie and so it wasn't real convenient and it wasn't
smart you know and so but people had those and then in let's see about 10 years ago there was 110
subscriptions to mobile phone carriers now in the United States there's 300 million so it was 110
million and now in 10 years it's really basically everybody has a cell phone or more than one pretty much
and so because of this increase you know EMFs are very important now but people wonder what they are
they've never heard of it and I'll ask people I'll even ask people in the medical profession or a
natural pathic or whatever and some of them don't even know and so but basically EMF stands for
electromagnetic fields and so a field is an area and it's an area of energy and it and it radiates from
electrical things but another name for EMFs which I think is important is EMR and the R stands for
radiation and radiation as we know is dangerous and so when I go to the dentist or whatever you know
they put this led thing over me and and just to radiate my brain but you know they're they're
taking precautions because they know this is dangerous and so and so that's why it's so important now
so yeah basically EMFs feels the radiation coming from all sorts of electrical things that are all
around us all the time are there natural sources of EMFs that are around us yes there are
some light and there's a magnetic field from the earth's core but these things our bodies are
adjusted to it over the you know over the course of human beings and and and they're and we're
in tune with those but the but the but the radiation levels now coming from from the different things
that are going on now are millions and millions of times stronger and higher and different so our
bodies going like what what in the world is happening you know what are these influences that are
hitting me you know so yeah so what would you call the difference between a natural EMF and would
you call them unnatural EMFs or a man made EMF okay so since man made EMFs are millions of
times stronger than nature's sources of EMR I guess you would probably say what makes man made EMFs
or EMR dangerous to not just humans but also animals in plant life yeah and that's a good question
too so what we do for EMF inspecting is we're scientific so we're not and so there are people who get
the different meters and so forth and they and they're looking for ghosts or whatever and but what
we do is scientific so we base what we do on levels and not let's say national levels or anything
like that but upon building biology and and and safe levels of scientists from around the world have
discovered and they're in their researching and so we base our scientific and our meters are very
accurate and so we can tell what is the real levels of radiation coming off of these things and
hitting the people and then we can say okay these are safe levels so it's so it's very scientific
but the reason that's harmful and this is what people need to understand is because our bodies
are electric our bodies are electric and when a person has heart trouble a lot of times they'll
give them a pacemaker you know which is electric our brain ways are electric or even the little chemical
processes taking place in our bodies are electric so therefore electricity affects us it affects us
and can actually mess up the uh and you know it's so amazing right our bodies are so amazing and God
made them and they're so intricate and beautiful and wonderful and you just have a look around at nature
everything has living has DNA everything living has DNA and in DNA in our cells is like the hard drive
of a computer and it has all this information that will replicate cells and keep us going and
and so some if you look at the double helix of a DNA it looks like an antenna and it actually can
pick up you know waves of electricity coming at us and and and and mess up that whole they've even found
can break the strands of DNA and this is from and this is not just from going to get an X-ray
at the doctor but this is from lower level like a Wi-Fi cell phones things like that can break the DNA
and when that happens well it can cause diseases and horrible horrible things it messes with our immune
system and so I'm just gonna tell you some of the things that can cause because people need to know
nervous system problems fatigue stress panic attacks which is very common sleep disturbances again
very a lot of those happening insomnia headaches heart issues we talked about the heart skin issues
pains and eggs eyes foggy thinking depression anxiety they're gonna link with suicide ear and nose
throat digestive infertility that's a biggie right now where where many couples cannot have children
damages to fetus there's a rise in autism leukemia cancer which you guys you know
are about cancer because if if the cells are not replicating correctly they can start reproducing cancer
you know cells and then that would keep going and so yeah so this is really like I said it's scientific
it's for real and it's a big deal now with all the electronic things going on and all of the
conditions that were on that list those are all conditions that you have read about in research
that you base your business off of that's been done around the globe am I correct on that absolutely
yeah because I do not want to give out any false information now here's one thing you have to take
into consideration because when you google you can get both sides of anything kind of you know
and I think you need to look at like where is the information coming from so for us we look at
independent peer reviewed research so they're not influenced by big money no one's paying them off
it's like it's not like oh yeah we hired our own scientists to come up with what we want but it's
independent and there are thousands of studies awesome studies that are done and easy to find
bio initiative report it's great people can look that up and these again are our independent
scientists researchers and not quacks I mean they're head of you know clinics and PhDs and
you know they're very very intelligent and highly respected people and they are saying we've got
to do something we've got to do something actually in 2015 to over 200 scientists and researchers
like we're talking went to the World Health and United Nations and said you must do something about
this and you you have to you know set some standards do something help the world save us right
and and but the dragging the feet you know and political and all that is just so slow that people are
not protected yeah which is where grassroots businesses or organizations like yours are so
important because it's starting instead of a top down effect which is going to be difficult to change
within our governmental structure we need to go to building from that foundation up is starting with
individuals and educating them which then we'll begin to influence what happens in the tears above
them so that being said can you give me a little background on how you got started in this field
and the business that you and your wife Loray have created sure so actually we we have been ministers
and pastors for many years and now we're we're still involved but we're more retired from that or
semi-retired and so actually we were we heard a sermon on dreams so now and again I want to say I'm
not a real spooky person so you know in fact I don't give many dreams but but I was kind of in between
waking up and sleeping and and God put it into my heart he really did and and I started to study
about EMFs researched it and and and just the more I did the more I got a passion and burden for it
and and so I took training and and just well you have to continually research it because now I mean
even 5G and everything they keep coming up with new stuff and but yeah and then we started our business
and we're now in the top of Google for for Twin Cities and and God has blessed us and and people are
very very thankful very very happy and grateful and thankful for what we do because there's not a lot
of us to do it and there's like I said a lot of disinformation so and again like we were saying
we were talking earlier before we started about how people are addicted to their technology and
they love it and they don't necessarily want to see it here that it's dangerous to them but
sometimes you need to hear what what is the truth because the truth can set you free and I um
I was reading a verse this morning from Proverbs and it says understanding is a fountain of life to
those who have it is that powerful so understanding is a fountain of life and and what you guys do is so
awesome you know and and what I like with the holistic and everything is that you're looking at all
different facets of a person's life right we're specialists so we look at the EMF piece which of course
we consider is very important but you look at it you know the food and the diet and all and nutrition
and all this and that's and that's important because we're a whole person and a whole body and so yeah
so anyway we got into it and and we're very excited and very and very passionate because you know
for us it's um it's not just a business it's like we want to help people and then that's the yeah
we um we did an inspection on our on our pastor's house and I went in his office and I'm
going to his really strong reading and I'm thinking the poor pastor are you getting zapped you know
so we turned off everything in his office everything in his office I'm I tested again still getting
zapped so I thought okay so I went around the opposite wall in the other room and here he's got his
Wi-Fi router so okay okay I unplugged that I come back around in his office I tested again
he's still getting zapped I go back around it was Apple TV Apple TV and it wasn't even on it was plugged in
but it was not on and it was sending pulsing signals right through the wall and right into his lap
really into him so um it wasn't good oh my goodness yeah if there was one thing that you could
tell a new listener who's maybe just being introduced to EMFs or has heard some misinformation out there
and so this is really a new opportunity for them to begin to build their foundation of knowledge and
understanding is there anything that you would love to to give them for a tidbit of wisdom or a piece
of advice as they begin on this journey to understanding EMFs and how it plays a role in their life
and in their health yeah well um it's a big subject so but they on our research page on our website
the mfinspecting.com we have a number of videos and those are are really good and that would
give people interested and give them some information and we have one and he was a lawyer his name was
Jimmy Gonzalez he got cancer in three places in his brain in his hand and by his hip
where he kept his cell phone where he held his cell phone and he's testifying before this committee
that how dangerous it is and he ended up dying and I don't know if the committee did anything
but is very very powerful testimony so um yeah so so as far as what they can do um well I guess what
we when we say is you know get an inspection um you know because what we do we can find it and we'll
go to houses where where people are into it you know I mean because if there's no awareness they don't
you know contact us but some awareness but we'll get people are really into I mean we shut off our
Wi-Fi at night and we do this and that and the other thing and but we will find issues in their house
because there's why it's invisible odorless tasteless most of us there are people that have
sensitivity but but many people don't and so they don't even know that's great information and I
will definitely let people know about going to your website it's good to have a website that you
use as a teaching tool so as we close this out today I want to let anybody who's watching know
that um Jim and his wife Lorraine's EMF inspecting website is www.emfinspecting.com
if you have questions you can email them at help at emfinspecting.com or you can call them directly
at 651-230-9429 could I share one more thing please do I would love that okay so this is a quote
and this is from 5gspaceappeal.org okay this is a this is a website where a person can go
and sign up for the 5g appeal which is appealing to the nations and the United Nations and the world
and the and the governments to do something about 5g it's to stop the rollout and to the research
and study it individuals or organizations can sign up here and it's called the 5gspaceappeal
and the reason it's called that is because they want to put all these things in outer space to
and sap is there you know so those other sort of globe is totally covered with EMFs and strong
and everything but any rate here's the quote it says the accumulated clinical evidence of sick
and injured human beings experimental evidence of damage to DNA cells organ systems in a wide
variety of plants and animals and evidence that the major diseases of modern civilization cancer
heart disease and diabetes are in large part caused by electromagnetic pollution that's EMF
it forms a literature base of well over 10,000 peer-reviewed studies and if the telecommunications
industries plans for 5g come to fruition no person no animal no bird no insect and no plan
plant on earth will be able to avoid exposure 24 hours a day 365 days a year to levels of RF
radiation that are tens to hundreds of times greater than what exists today already without any
possibility of escape anywhere on the planet and then it says this these 5g plans threaten to
provoke serious irreversible effects on humans and permanent damage to all of Earth's echo systems
so that's right yeah yeah that is so powerful and so that's why we do what we do and that's
what you do what you do so thank you for having us my pleasure thank you so much Jim